the engine of growth in the super bubble
was the American consumer that consumed
more than it produced and for various
reasons we were able to build up a
current account deficit that was mounted
eventually to six and a half or seven
percent of the GNP and also the
consumers were householders we'll be
drawing from their equity from their
mortgages which was actually about the
same size at the end is slightly larger
about 900 billion dollars annualized
that was the engine of growth for the
world and that engine is now switched
off it's been knocked out so you need
another engine and in my opinion in the
end it will be the problem connected
with their energy global warming which
is threatening to our civilization and
is not actually addressed needs to be
addressed at the same time we are also
concerned about the ever rising costs of
exploring for fossil fuels particularly
oil and and of course energy dependence
and all those three factors required to
develop alternate source of energy and
invest in energy saving investments and
that ought to be the motor of the
economy that is going to take us out of
the recession where you're going to have
unemployed resources and those resources
are better employed rather than paying
unemployment benefits bettering employed
in put to use in that direction that is
where I see the way out of the global
recession or depression
that we are currently heading into